avec morgane nadal propriétaire d'une
discothèque à béthune bonsoir morgan ban
merci d'être avec nous une première
réaction déjà cette réouverture du 9
juillet une bonne surprise on imagine
vous vous y attendiez oui oui on s'y
attendait parce que ça avait fuité alors
une bonne surprise c'est en demies tacle
le sentiment est partagé c'est pas on
ice est pas vraiment un sentiment de
joie puisque après 15 mois de fermeture
nos établissements ne valent plus un
clou en élevage 0 euros 85 % de la
profession restera fermée car avec un
pass sanitaire nos établissements sur
moins fréquentées puisque seulement 5 à
6% déjà ne sont actuellement vacciner un
gros soulagement pour les saisonniers
qui eux vont pouvoir travailler et qui
eux pourront faire du chiffre d'affaires
pour pour l'hiver on a vraiment éviter
le pire parce qu'on aurait pu nous
mettre un pass sanitaires et un
protocole mais rappelons-le rappelons le
quand même que le pass sanitaires pour
nous c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'inéquitable par rapport
à toutes les autres professions car
rappelons le nous serons la seule
concession en france à avoir pas
sanitaires et ça pose vraiment le
problème du nine équité entre les lieux
de libertinage les bars à ambiance
musicaux qui ouvre la nuit des
restaurants ambiance musicaux également
aux musicales perdant qui ouvre la nuit
donc ça crée un problème de rupture
d'égalité on se dit que on a on va
prendre notre mal en patience jusqu'au
30 septembre
parce qu'au 30 septembre c'est la fin
c'est la fin de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire fin de jeu ça oui morgan
dalbis courrier vous espérez parce que
c'est vrai qu'on le sait quand même c
c'est le bon sens on est vraiment ravis
pour vous et pour nous d'ailleurs de
pouvoir revenir faire la fête dans l'est
dans les discothèques mais mais vous le
savez c'est un endroit par définition
confiné où il ya une promiscuité on va
pas danser avec des masques
le pass sanitaire c'était un minimum
quand même j'estime que si on permet à
des lieux libertinage de rouvrir c'est à
dire un lieu au libertinage a par
définition des gens copule par centaines
j'estime que si ces gens là peuvent
rouvrir sans pass sanitaire pourquoi la
pause et à des jeunes qui vont
simplement les boire un verre en
discothèque
maintenant on attend avec impatience le
30 septembre qui est la fin du régime de
la sortie de crise sanitaire
aujourd'hui pas sanitaire donc
obligatoire ça veut dire tests pcr
antigénique où les fameuses deux doses
de vaccin pour vous ça va peut-être
encourager les jeunes à aller se faire
vacciner c'est une éventualité comment
vous sentez les choses alors j'espère
qu'on ne traînera pas se passe
sanitaires comme un boulet il est
certain qu'on s'est servi des
discothèques temps on les prend en otage
pour faire vacciner la jeunesse j'espère
que la jeunesse jouera le jeu parce
qu'il en va de notre survie financière
après si les jeunes ne se font pas
vacciner
j'espère que économiquement on arrivera
à tenir le choc et que l'état nous
soutiendra parce que rappelons le au 30
août on nous enlève le masque à oxygène
et c'est là où la casse risque d'arriver
dans notre secteur d'activité qui comme
le rappelait votre collègue tout à
l'heure a déjà subi cent trente et une
fermeture de discothèques clairement là
vous avez deux semaines pour préparer la
réouverture on imagine que voilà vous
étiez un petit peu au courant en amont
enfin rien n'était sûr parce que ça va
vous suffire
alors moi pour ma part je ne rouvrirait
pas comme 85 % de mes collègues parce
que comme on voulait indiqué travailler
avec 6 % 2
de clientèle serre que si pour
uniquement seulement 6% des jeunes sont
vaccinés bond sera pas possible pour les
autres bien entendu qui se sont préparés
bon jusqu'au 9 juillet ça leur laisse
quand même 20 jours je pense que ça ira
ce sont des professionnels qui depuis 16
mois ont eu le temps de réfléchir à leur
ouverture donc oui je pense que ils y
arriveront avec et émettront en sécurité
leurs petits anges et aucun doute sur ça
vous dit 6 % de la clientèle parce que
vacciner d'enfin ya aussi la possibilité
de faire des tests antigénique à
l'entrée c'est trop compliqué à mettre
en oeuvre mais alors le pass sanitaires
sur le papier c'est sexy je veux dire
mais dans la réalité c'est très
difficile à appliquer je veux dire les
jeunes iront une fois ou deux fois
ce maître de coton tige dans le nez mais
ils n'iront pas toutes les semaines pour
sortir en discothèque
il savait on a fait quand même quelques
enquêtes auprès de notre clientèle pour
savoir qu'ils ne font pas
systématiquement
c'est une très bonne nouvelle pour nos
saisonniers qui eux vont pouvoir
travailler puisque les jeunes avant de
partir en vacances en général on est un
passage obligatoire à la discothèque
lorsqu'on va sur les sauts les littoraux
donc ils feront cet effort mais pour le
reste de la profession
le sentiment est très partagée taux de
remplissage de 100% donc en extérieur
75% en intérieur comment vous allez
gérer cette dit oddo mire alors bon on
mettra nos agents de sécurité se
mettront avec des conteurs et des
conteurs donc comme comme on l'a déjà
fait dans d'autres situations
ce sera difficile à mettre en place mais
j'ai aucun doute sur le fait que nos
collègues sans les 15% qui ouvriront y
arriva puisqu'on a toujours en
permanence était face à de nouvelles
normes et de nouvelles règles
alors la seule crainte on en parlait
entre collègues c'est que cette nouvelle
norme du pass sanitaires
reste à deviner mais ternat mme kouao
ses notes c'est notre grosse crainte
merci beaucoup morgan d'un propriétaire
d'une discothèque à béthune d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france